Another Thing That Doctor Bright Is Not Allowed
To Do At The Foundation: No sending Nigerian
Prince-esque spam emails to the Church of
the Broken God!
Email is a vital communication tool to keep
any workplace running smoothly, even the SCP
Foundation!
However, like any great tool, it can also
be used for evil.
Or just a bit of chaos.
Dr. Bright decided to play a prank, and earn
a bit of extra cash, by posing as a sentient
machine in need of help from the Church of
the Broken God.
“Pls respond…need 100,000 US Dollars to
fight against the Sarkites…for the glory
of Mekhane…send ur routing number and bank
information ASAP.”
The Church quickly wired the money, and were
enraged when they learned they had been duped.
They retaliated by leaving flaming bags of
dog poop on the front steps of several Foundation
Sites.
Needless to say, Dr. Bright has been encouraged
to find another outlet for his more mischievous
impulses.
They did keep the money though.